recurrir al flujo del río o esperar que
llueva Esas son las opciones que tienen
los miembros de algunas comunidades que
viven en avisán la capital económica de
Costa de Marfil donde habitan miles de
personas que no poseen acceso a agua
potable tenemos un problema de agua Aquí
deberían hacer algo al respecto hace más
de un año que no tenemos agua en la casa
todos los días Tenemos que venir aquí a
recoger agua estamos cansados de eso los
marfileños tienen desplegados
recipientes de plástico dentro de sus
casas porque el agua puede gotear de las
cañerías en mitad de la noche lo
funcionarios argumentan que estos
problemas son una consecuencia de la
falta de energía eléctrica y en estas
circunstancias las precarias condiciones
sanitarias derivan en enfermedades
necesitamos tener baños limpios y la
casa tiene que estar limpia y para eso
necesitamos agua si no está limpio los
niños respiran los olores la suciedad Y
eso los puede enfermar
no es fácil algunos en nuestros niños
contraen infecciones estomacales
actualmente tengo una hermana embarazada
en la casa que tiene una infección una
infección crónica
este miércoles se celebra un nuevo día
mundial del agua el cual fue instaurado
por Naciones Unidas en 1993 según la
organización internacional una de cada
cuatro personas en todo el mundo carece
agua potable y alrededor de un millón y
medio mueren cada año por enfermedades
vinculadas a la falta de agua e higiene